should shale gas and shale oil
extraction be subject to environmental
impact assessment the industry says the
impact of shale's rock fracturing
technology is minimal opponents say if
there's the remotest danger then it
should be assessed and it's time anyway
to rewrite 28-year-old legislation for
new technologies
negativity
shale gas and oil are most abundant in
poland germany and austria a vote is to
be held on wednesday
significant support for 1500 italian
workers laid off from their vehicle and
it enterprises fell victim to major
changes in global trading patterns the
workers will share some three million
seven hundred thousand euros from the
european globalization adjustment fund
for retraining finding new work or just
surviving
existing
a last shout for meps demanding an
immediate increase to europe's co2
emissions reduction targets 2020 targets
stand at 20 percent many meps want to
increase that to 25 or even 30 percent
the idea was bundled in with measures
defeated in committee last month to
restructure a key tool in europe's co2
reduction efforts the emissions trading
system which is suffering from low
prices
everyone it seems is worried about where
next
minutes
is